[Music]
after being canceled after only three
seasons fan outcry led to longmire being
rescued by netflix for another three
seasons but now that it's over are you
longing for more longmire these 15 shows
will fill the neo-western hole in your
heart left behind by the beloved series
amazon prime's bosch is the perfect
example of a show that captures the vibe
of longmire without sharing its western
setting the series stars titus weliver
who sci-fi fans may know as the man in
black from lost as los angeles detective
harry bosch not unlike longmire the
series is based on a set of novels
written by michael connolly this
procedural drama is structured by case
of the week crimes that bosch needs to
solve
simultaneously it features overarching
season-long and even series-long story
arcs that weave in greater themes as the
seasons progress connolly's other bosch
books of which there are over 20 are
mined for story inspiration the series
wrapped up its seventh and final season
in 2021 but fans didn't have to weep for
long the show quickly earned a spin-off
fans of longmire are sure to like how
bosh intertwines characters individual
episodes and big picture plots
if you've got a hankering for a real
western after enjoying longmire go back
in time with hell on wheels this
historical drama ran on amc for five
seasons from 2011 to 2016. the series is
set in the years after the american
civil war and stars anson mounds as
cullen bohannon a former confederate
soldier who joins the union pacific
railroad col meaney co-stars as thomas
doc durant a real historical figure who
invested in the first transcontinental
railroad common plays elam ferguson a
recently freed enslaved person who
becomes cullen's assistant and bodyguard
the series and the characters move
across the country as the railroad is
built this allows for many procedural
scenarios the laborers surveyors
builders sex workers and everyone else
who travels along with the encampment
refer to themselves as hell on wheels
giving the show its title they're well
worth getting to know
in amc's the sun british actor pierce
brosnan heads to the american west from
that simple starting point things get
complicated as the sun likes to play
with time the main setting is 1917 where
brosnan plays eli mccullough the iconic
first son of texas he secures his legacy
as a wealthy oil tycoon by killing
threatening and deceiving his way to the
top
in this life if you don't move forward
you die
the sun also takes the viewer back to
1850 where a young eli played by jacob
loughland learns the ways of the
comanche and becomes a respected warrior
the show also jumps forward to 1988
where eli's granddaughter jeannie played
by lois smith uncovers family secrets
it's a pretty neat setup and though amc
only gave the show two seasons it's
still worth a watch
the fx action drama sons of anarchy
could certainly fill the longmire hole
in your heart the series follows the
members of an outlaw motorcycle club
rooted in the central valley of
california charlie hunnam stars as
jackson jack teller the vice president
of the sons of anarchy motorcycle club
he begins to question his role in the
club after discovering the journals of
his deceased father the club's former
president
throughout the series the club is
involved in many illegal activities so
while this series may be like longmire
in many respects the long arm of the law
is considered the bad guy here always
looking to shut them down and toss their
members in jail the series also
addresses racism in the world of outlaw
motorcycle clubs the role of vigilantism
and government corruption
the netflix series bloodline begins with
john rayburn's ominous voice he says
sometimes you know something's coming
you can feel it in the air in your gut
and you don't sleep at night the voice
in your head is telling you that
something is going to go terribly wrong
and there's nothing you can do to stop
it that's how i felt when my brother
came home as you might guess from this
intense introduction bloodline is
steeped in secrets crime and tense
reunions the story follows the rayburn
siblings of the florida keys when the
aforementioned black sheep of the family
returns from who knows where his
presence causes enough tension to kill
off the family patriarch while longmire
might be set out west bloodline offers
up the same thrilling ambiance in a more
paradisical atmosphere come on in the
turquoise water is fine
hbo's deadwood ran for three seasons in
the 2000s wrapping up years later with a
2019 movie the show is a historical
western set in deadwood south dakota in
the 1870s timothy oliphant stars as seth
bullock a sheriff turned hardware store
owner ian mcshane plays saloon owner al
swerrigen as deadwood grows from a
ramshackle spot into a blossoming town
south dakota itself prepares for a more
official law-abiding existence that
means cleaning up the rabble complex
drama ensues weaving together episodic
arcs and lengthier storylines involving
government corruption loyalty and the
early days of american crime deadwood is
well known for its sharp riding and
stellar performances it has also become
known for its incredible amount of
swearing one report counts a total of
2980
f-bombs dropped during the show's three
seasons with one occurring every 1.56
seconds deadwood offers up the western
procedural ambience longmire fans crave
and a degree of profanity so immense
it's almost awe-inspiring
kevin costner's most recent western
adventure is a modern one called
yellowstone which makes its home on the
paramount network the series follows the
dutton family sixth generation owners of
the largest working ranch in the country
costner stars as the patriarch john
dutton the drama hinges on outsiders
attempts at gaining access to the
dutton's land conflicts with the
neighboring native reservation and a
whole lot of family secrets the dutton
family features three grown kids casey
jamie and beth
their lives form much of the backbone of
the series encompassing substance abuse
illicit relationships and frustrated
dreams all in all yellowstone is an
emotional exciting and altogether
engrossing drama with western flair in
short perfect for anyone who loves
longmire
after starring in deadwood timothy
oliphant traveled into the future some
130 years to star in fx's modern drama
justified he plays deputy u.s marshal
raylyn gibbons after shooting a miami
mobster givens is transferred to
kentucky where he happens to be from
it's not a happy homecoming drama
violence secrets and lies ensue often
tangled together justified ran for six
seasons and was critically acclaimed
throughout its run walton goggins
performance as boyd crowder a white
supremacist creature who heads up the
area's criminal underground earned
particular praise among other stellar
roles
justified is based on author elmore
leonard's work especially fire and the
whole the success of justified inspired
leonard to write another givens-centric
novel raylen the book came out in 2012
shortly before leonard's death in 2013.
here's where we get a little
international with this list 10 star is
a british crime drama that revolves
around a london detective who's tasked
with becoming the police chief of a
canadian town in the rocky mountains its
old west meets old world not exactly a
common combination but as it turns out a
fascinating one tim roth stars as james
jim wirth the detective who moves his
family to canada to escape his troubled
past the weird thing about this show is
that when jim drinks he becomes his
violent alter ego jack devlin it's
intense surprisingly fun and a bit weird
all at the same time christina hendricks
co-stars as elizabeth bradshaw an
executive with north stream oil the
company that dominates the town she
tries to balance chief worth's presence
with the biker gangs criminals and oil
workers of the town
tin star spans three seasons which first
aired on sky atlantic then moved to
amazon interestingly however season
three or series three as the brits call
it takes place back in liverpool england
this omits the western feel of the show
but not to worry it still maintains its
crime thriller ambiance
while some of the shows on this list can
get pretty dark and dramatic happen
leonard is one that embraces its humor
this mystery crime drama stars james
purefoy as hap collins a blue-collar
dude who spent time in prison as well as
michael kenneth williams as leonard pine
a black gay vietnam veteran set in the
1980s the series takes place in east
texas where happ and leonard team up on
a get rich quick scheme soon enough they
pull ex-wives townsfolk other criminals
and lawmen into their fold the show was
created by novelist joe r lansdale and
is based on his happen leonard novels in
many ways it's unlike any other show on
this list blending together comedy grit
lawlessness and outright absurdity if
you're longing for that longmire
attitude but you'd also like to crack a
smile once in a while happen leonard is
a great choice
i'll do what i can
we're going across the pond again for
this next entry though itv's broad
church doesn't have the western edge
that longmire does its fascinating
portrait of a town in crisis will no
doubt lure you in the series is set in
the fictional english village of
broadchurch here detectives alec hardy
played by david tennant and ellie miller
played by olivia coleman are forced to
team up despite the vast difference in
their personalities
season one follows their journey as they
attempt to solve the enigmatic killing
of a local boy
broadchurch being a small town other
townsfolk soon become involved things
grow more and more complex in seasons 2
and 3 wrapping the whole series up in a
twisty mysterious bow the setting of the
show provides just as much ambiance as
the chilling crimes themselves the white
cliffs grey skies and rough seas are
basically characters unto themselves if
the mystery aspect of longmire drew you
in you'll find broadchurch downright
addictive
we're staying in england for this next
entry but can you blame us the leading
man is just that good in the bbc one
crime drama luther idris elba stars as
john luther a police detective for the
serious crime unit which sounds silly
but is official luther often gets sucked
into the crimes he investigates
especially those of serial killer alice
morgan played by ruth wilson the two
spend the majority of the series as both
nemesis and companions infusing this
dark crime thriller with electric
tension luthor is technically a
mini-series with only two to six
episodes per season making the entire
five-season series totally bingeable
there was supposed to be an american
remake but it fell apart back in 2017.
there is still chatter about a luther
movie so you best get into it now
are you up for a little sci-fi horror to
go along with your neo-western if so
sci-fi's wynonna earp might be right up
your alley
it stars melanie scrafano as the titular
character the great-great-granddaughter
of legendary old west law man wyatt
earth that legacy isn't all it's cracked
up to be she's haunted by the outlaws
her ancestor killed who take the form of
undead revenants luckily on her 27th
birthday she discovers that she's
inherited the ability to send them back
to hell with a little help from
peacemaker her ancestors magic gun
wynonna erp ran for four seasons on
sci-fi before being canceled in 2021
don't count it out just yet though the
show's passionate fanbase is working
overtime to secure the future of winona
earth if you're short on time and
looking for a single season mini-series
to binge check out netflix's godless sat
in 1884 godless begins when young outlaw
roy goode played by jack o'connell runs
out on his cruel mentor he soon stumbles
onto lebel new mexico a town run and
populated almost entirely by women as it
turns out most of the men of labelle
died in a mining accident leaving the
town's women to run it as they please
jeff daniels also stars as frank griffin
the venomous outlaw good flees from the
mini-series was a hit earning its cast
and crew a handful of emmy awards and a
place on multiple best of the year lists
banshee captures neo-western style much
like longmire does with a major
geographical twist
set in pennsylvania amish country
banshee stars anthony starr as an ex-con
who assumes the identity of the town's
incoming sheriff to hide from a powerful
crime lord called mr rabbit when the
sheriff is killed the ex-con whose name
we never learn swipes his identity and
shows up in banshee pa masquerading as
the town's new lawman
banshee earned mixed reviews some
watchers love it while others criticize
its intense violence and gratuitous sex
scenes so yeah it's a bit more wild than
longmire but it still utilizes that same
gritty procedural style in a unique
setting the show ran for four seasons on
cinemax and definitely lives up to the
lurid nature of that network's
reputation it's at least worth checking
out check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]